l'accueil du site internet indique
simplement que le journal suspense et
publication jusqu'à la fin de
l'opération militaire russe en ukraine
pour ses parutions en ligne comme pour
celle au format papier la décision du
journal indépendant russe novaïa gazeta
intervient après un deuxième
avertissement des autorités en moins
d'une semaine officiellement pour
manquement à la loi sur les agents de
l'étranger le rédacteur en chef de
novaïa gazeta dmitri mouratov a reçu en
2021 le prix nobel de la paix pour son
engagement au sein de son journal il a
décidé la semaine dernière de faire don
de sa médaille d'une belle à un fonds
destiné à aider les blessés et les
réfugiés d'ukrainiens lundi jour de la
suspension de son journal il a fait
savoir à ses lecteurs qu'il n'y avait
pas d'autre solution que c'était une
décision terrible et douloureuse mais
qu'il fallait se protéger les uns des
autres
depuis le déclenchement de l'opération
militaire les autorités russes ont
renforcé la répression de ce cas
qualifie de fausses informations les
sites de nombreux médias russes ou
étrangers ont été bloqués novaïa gazeta
était jusque là l'un des tout derniers
bastions de la presse libre encore en
activité en russie notamment connu pour
ses enquêtes sur la corruption et les
atteintes aux droits humains en
tchétchénie novaïa gazeta faisait figure
d'exception dans le paysage médiatique
russe cet engagement a coûté la vie à
six de ses collaborateurs depuis les
années 1990 dont la célèbre journaliste
anna politkovskaïa assassinée en 2006